he is Peter King back here on the riches
and show how you doing Peter rich
everything's okay how about it's good I
appreciate it you texting me on my
vacation to see how I was taking in the
Michigan game while I was overseas I
appreciated you terrible for you you
couldn't see the game no they don't the
n-c-double-a for all of its money
grabbing I don't think they had an
overseas streaming partner which is nuts
to me
hey rich I got an email to my column
this week from a guy who lives in the
Faroe Islands effe roie okay which is
200 miles north of Scotland okay in the
in the North Sea okay
and I was so incredulous but I get
eating meat at any an email from the
Faroe Islands I called him and I said
man how do you know the NFL he goes hey
NFL game pass i watch NFL red zone every
Sunday hey I'm telling you the breaking
I'm telling you I'm telling you the UK
does love the NFL Peter that is real it
is real in it I don't know a lot of fans
I got to play games over there you know
it's just really just trying to break
into a market just about dollars and
cents I really do I had conversations
and like I told you this in our in our
text this past year some some Brits who
I spoke to said that Shakima Griffin
even broke through the news over there
yeah in the UK yeah you know so as a cut
where we're 20 days from the first round
of the draft what's Cleveland thinking
doing kicking the tires on everybody
right now as you can tell Peter you know
rich III think that you know when Joe
Thomas got hurt last year I remember
having this conversation with him about
the Browns and about Shashi brown and
about the whole plan there and the whole
plan was to accumulate a ridiculous
historic number of graphics build much
of the infrastructure like particularly
on both lines and then you know finally
you know get all your get all your skill
players and
and you know and get your quarterback
and all that and I mean I think one of
the reasons is Sashi Brown got fired is
that they just had too many guys you
know who didn't who who didn't seem that
they were those guys you know who are
the infrastructure guys for the next
eight or ten years and so but I do think
that this year you know the Browns are
not in hey you know let's stop it let's
let's know they are in the let's stop
gathering draft picks and let's start
building a team that we could start to
win with and so that's why I think they
go to best players at one and four
they'll take a quarterback at number one
my guess would be darn 'old or poor Josh
Allen and then they would go with best
player on their board at number four and
that'll be in my opinion either say Quan
Berkeley or Chubb hmm so they take Chubb
and stick them on the other side of
miles garret and go to battle on that
defensive side that they get the maybe
triggerman for the next decade decade
and a half if they're lucky with Jarvis
Landry and Josh Gordon I mean how does
that not win 8 games I'll be honest
Peter I know that a lot of people might
think that's crazy but that defense well
but but hang on hang on Taylor - it
could win 8 games in 2019 but in 2018
you have to count on Tyrod Taylor being
a really good quarterback I don't know
that he is one he might be you know the
people who've been with them and and all
the sort of analytics people to pro
Football Focus people they love Tyrod
Taylor yeah and I have to say I haven't
seen it I mean I've I'm you know I'm
from Missouri
Tyrod Taylor I like him but I have not
seen him you know you watch the game
against Jacksonville you say God make a
play but again Jacksonville is good ok
so we we know we know then they're
taking a quarterback at the
what it what is happening it would with
the Giants then that means that they
hold all the cards Giants hold all the
cards and they can either get probably
three ones and something from Buffalo to
move down to twelve but the only way
they do that in my opinion is if Dave
gentlemen and and Pat Shermer convinced
John Mayer and Steve Tisch in essence
well it's not really that way but if
they convince the rest of the building
that listen we're fine with Eli for the
next two years he's fit as a fiddle
he'll be fine for the next two years now
if I were them I take quarterback at
number two and I'd resist temptation but
you have to really like one of the
quarterbacks and you know whether it's
rosin whether it's Alan whether it's
Baker Mayfield you're gonna have to read
it or darn 'old if he doesn't go one
then you really have to start saying to
yourself okay we we have to be sure with
one of those guys at number one and I'll
tell you this rich I was talking to a an
NFL Draft decider yeah the guy who was
gonna make his picks in 20 days for his
team we were talking and I said how
concerned are you with what Jim Mora
said about Josh Rosen and he goes quite
concerned and because he said that's a
guy who lived with Josh Ravin for three
years and he obviously has some
questions about him but be that as it
may the interesting part of the
conversation beyond that was that he
said that if I were a quarterback at the
top of this draft I would pray to go to
the New York Giants because Eli Manning
not only is a great guy and a really
good player but you're gonna be behind
him and you are going to learn how to
play quarterback in the NFL this guy
will help you and and look hey Josh
McCown will help you too and I think
Josh McCown is a coach on the field and
and all that stuff he'd be great but I
think there'd be something to play with
Eli Manning for two years that would be
great for any of those guys if I were
the Giants and could get
Josh Rosen in with Eli Manning for two
years I would absolutely love that if I
were a Giants fan well a couple things
you just said I want to I want to
expound upon in a couple minutes I have
left with you Peter King of the mm QB
let's take the Jim Morris tough he's
coming on the show on Thursday I heard
him on Dan show before that he was on
the NFL Network he's been on path to
draft all week he said that this stuff
has been misconstrued that he has been
as positive about this kid that he loves
him and that a lot of this stuff is
being spun you spoke to him did you when
you spoke with him get the sense that he
had some reservations about Josh Rosen
being a professional quarterback of
franchise note I would say the only
reservation that I spent from him is
whether he was going to be absolutely
totally a hundred percent all-in
you know because he's got a lot of other
things in his life that he likes that he
likes to do you know and I bring up Josh
Freeman okay Josh Freeman failed in
Tampa for a lot of reasons for most of
which was that he didn't want to work on
Tuesdays during the season and you know
there's 31 other quarterbacks who did
want to work on Tuesday not necessarily
10 hours but 6 I think you know and you
just have to do that if you're a
quarterback in the NFL you got to walk
in the building Wednesday and have a
good idea about what the game plan is
because you've already been talking
about it with your coordinator and
quarterback coach but but that's really
about the only thing I think that Jim
Mora the vast majority of what he told
me last Sunday was positive on Josh
Rosen that seemed to have gotten lost in
the wash I don't blame people for
picking out some of the things but I do
blame people for picking out only the
the quasi negative things you're the
Millenial stuff all that stuff I get
moorim in in 88% of the conversation
that I had with him was was very
positive about Josh Roswell and then
then you mentioned as a trade partner
for the Giants that could let them a ton
of first-round picks etc being the
Buffalo Bills
Sam Donald as being as being tyre kicked
by the Broncos today sitting there at
five and then the Patriots as you know
have two first round selections suss out
I would be shocked if the Patriots moved
up into the into the area of the top
four quarterbacks I reach how can they
do that they need a left tackle they
need they need to rebuild this team
right now and they can't take all of
their draft capital and move up to
whatever it is I mean think about it
it's probably not even sensible for the
Giants to take three ones to go down to
number 12 right think about it and they
need to restock - so then what is how
are the Patriots gonna move way up so
then suss out the trade market is it
really just the bill I mean cuz the
Broncos are sitting there at five again
if the name if the first name if the
first name that comes out of Juke
Adele's mouth and twenty days is Josh
Allen then the Giants phone a Dave
gentleman's phone line is white hot to
the touch at that night sorry right I
totally agree so we'll see if they do
anything my gut feeling is they would
take Sam Donald at number two and then
the Jets would take may feel their rosin
at number three but those are all
guesses let me just say one other thing
rich how can there be a trade up in
there there will be a trade I believe
either with Miami or Buffalo if if when
Indianapolis picks at number six now
Chris Ballard I believe would love to go
down a few spots so that one of his top
four or five picks all mine quarterbacks
would still be available and he can pick
up another say second and maybe a four
to move down to the range of 11 or 12 I
think if the Colts could do that they
would last one for you Peter what
happened where do rg3 come from how did
that come on the radar I have no idea I
didn't even know he was under
consideration he's one of those guys who
so fell under the radar in it in my
opinion in my opinion this
is one of those deals that the Baltimore
Ravens should quite literally put this
guy on their roster maybe as a three but
maybe it too and just keep him for the
year get him back into football shape
get him back into a good foot into a
good quarterback room you know with
Flaco and basically see what you've got
at the end of this year entering into
2019 if I were them that's how I do it
piqué let's watch at again soon and
we'll definitely see you down in Dallas
Thanks the tongue thank you thank you
yeah that's a Peter King @s i underscore
peter king the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience